[Music]
it can be tough to find the time to
learn a new language but having link
available on the web iOS and Android
makes it that much easier to fit your
learning in the easiest way to find
extra time for learning is to listen
during dead time like while commuting or
walking the dog using the mobile apps
and the playlist feature allows me to
quickly pick up where I left off and
always be listening to my most recent
lessons I can add lessons to my playlist
either from the reader or lessons page
on the lessons page I just click the add
to playlist button when viewing my
lessons and click again to remove them
here I can also manage my playlists and
reorder or remove lessons as required
lessons added to my playlist are
automatically downloaded to the mobile
app when I open the app next I do have
to have an internet connection of course
but once downloaded these lessons are
also available to listen to offline my
listening time is tracked automatically
and I never have to worry about
downloading and managing audio files on
my phone I regularly add and remove
lessons from my playlist as I move on to
newer lessons and complete others I can
even read my lessons create links and
review while offline as long as I first
open the lesson while online any
progress I make is tracked and added to
my statistics next time I'm online with
this ability to have my new language
with me all the time
there are no more excuses happy linking